NARRATOR: Congratulations.
Your Kubernetes application
is in production,
and the number of services
you own are growing.
But as you scale your
services in production,
you also need to
scale your monitoring.
After all, you can't fix
what you don't monitor,
and your monitoring
needs to be as
reliable as your application.
Prometheus is the standard
Kubernetes monitoring system,
which helps you collect,
store, query, and alert
on metrics important
to your applications
and infrastructure.
As you scale up, it can become
challenging to configure
and manage Prometheus to keep
up with the volume of metrics
from all of your
successful services.
This can be a thankless task.
After all, your users don't
care about how you manage
your monitoring infrastructure.
They care about making
sure they can use your app.
Google Cloud Managed
Service for Prometheus
is designed to help you
scale your Prometheus-based
monitoring.
It's fully managed by Google,
removing operational toil
from tasks like charting
Prometheus servers,
managing complex
scrape configurations,
and federating Prometheus
servers to make a global data
source.
By using the same planet-scale
time series database
that Google uses for
its own monitoring,
Managed Service for
Prometheus enables
users to collect metrics at
incredible scale with zero
operational overhead.
This puts global monitoring
and alerting within reach,
enabling you to gather metrics
from all of your services
across the planet.
Metrics collection
within your GKE clusters
also becomes easier as
Managed Service for Prometheus
provides managed
collectors that you can
run in your various clusters.
These no longer need to maintain
state in your own environment,
as they are built to write to
and store metrics in Managed
Service for Prometheus.
All this said, Managed
Service for Prometheus
is an in-place replacement for
running your own Prometheus
servers, which means you
can keep using your existing
Prometheus alerts and your
existing Grafana dashboards.
Managed Service for Prometheus
supports any application that
uses PromQL to query metrics.
You can also utilize
its integrations
with Google Cloud Monitoring.
To get started, you'll
need to take two steps.
First, enable Managed
Service for Prometheus
in your GKE cluster and
deploy Prometheus collectors.
These can be deployed alongside
your existing Prometheus
servers.
These collectors
will be configured
to write metrics directly to
Managed Service for Prometheus.
Second, connect clients, such
as Grafana or other tools you
may use, to read Prometheus
metrics from Managed Service
for Prometheus.
And that's it.
With Managed Service
for Prometheus,
now you're ready to spend less
time configuring monitoring
infrastructure and more time
adding the next big feature
to your app.
Want to learn more?
Check out more details
in the links below.
[MUSIC PLAYING]